everyone is getting off television that
addiction of television we are moving to
the addiction of the internet and you're
watching this on the internet so i guess
it's good for us
a new belkin and harris interactive
study found that 30
of us internet users are considering
ending their cable plans um
and that by 2014 over 50
of the us internet population will be
watching tv online and that 40 of all
americans by 2014 we'll be watching tv
online uh are you guys have a graphic
for this no graphics this week it'd be
nice those numbers
next time let's do it yeah we'll get pie
charts next time somebody you have a so
you have a helper i you need pie charts
i said pie charts um
what do you guys think now i've cut the
cable i have no uh i'm not on the cable
i have internet and i have a little roku
box and that's it what about you guys i
i'm still paying for cable but this is
something that i feel bitter about every
month when i get the bill because i
barely watch anything on television i
mean my guilty pleasure is the real
housewives of whatever city they're
doing that season um and and i love it
because i like to watch stupid mindless
stuff after talking about stuff like uh
i don't know the grand bargain at work
right right um but i realized like it's
a waste of money i i'm addicted to
netflix i'm now getting into breaking
bad do you guys watch breaking bad i
haven't watched it oh it's bananas you
guys gotta check it out the comments are
gonna blow up ow you don't watch
breaking bad oh it's so good guys you
guys will get addicted it's okay so it's
a show about meth but it's
that show is like crack for me i cannot
stop watching it wait it's a show about
meth but it's like cracked it's not like
meth to you it's like cracked wait wait
crack crack cocaine okay sorry i thought
it was getting mixed no no no that makes
perfect sense it's just interesting it's
not like meth to you no no that's like
would be a little yeah no interest in
the meth or the or the crack but
anyway
you know what's insane to me scotch is
like vicodin that's how i go yeah i mean
so
weed is like cigarettes yeah you need a
chart for that
drug breakdown chart yes are you are you
hooked on uh the cable i cannot wait i
cannot you know it's like to me cable
television is like living in russia
right because you don't you don't get to
choose your cable provider yes they give
it to you and then they don't give you
any customer service they do they you
take it you're hey my internet went out
it's tough pound sand too bad yeah no
one gives it there's no one to talk to
they don't answer the phone i have
charter i hate them and i can't even get
the channels i want to get but i
couldn't get current tv when they were
still a thing and uh and so now i i i
hate it and i can't wait to get rid of
cable i can't believe we're still
using the timetable that the
network set up for us like why can't i
just go to abc.com and watch whatever
show i want to watch at any time of the
day well that is that's now starting
like things with netflix like with house
of cards where they gave you the whole
series at once and you can if you're
crazed and you can watch 24 hours in a
row or you can watch it over a month or
whatever but i get cable for honest to
god i get cable for boxing
because i i i could show you you might
be the last guy in america that watches
boxing yeah i like boxing oh see not
like a big boxing fan like i don't get
excited about uh fights but if someone's
watching it someone ordered it i'll be
like sure i'll come over i like nachos
the part that i think is fast
the part that i think is fascinating
about this is we think that monopolies
are just when it's one company that runs
everything but really the cable
companies there's about five big ones
and they've become one monopoly
themselves it's called an oligopoly
right is it oligopoly yeah so that's
basically what they've become because
it's five companies they sit in a
private boardroom where they negotiate
prices so nobody's giving you anything
better and then they give you 300
channels that you don't care about and
there's nothing and you have to take
them because you want espn so we're
going to give you 20 other things right
so uh yeah i can't wait to the bottom
line is i can't wait to get rid of
there's a special pit in hell for the
people who run the cable companies i
think yeah so what's keeping you on it
then that's the question because
everyone this is what everybody's saying
now oh i can get netflix and hbo go and
whatever so what it's like crack that's
like crack i i like you know i like to
be able to switch around and watch still
television is more convenient than doing
it the other way for me it's much more
convenient i like to i watch new shows
constantly all the time and so i like to
i don't want to have to go to the and
sometimes they break it up like it is
hard to see some new shows they break it
up too much and just like how people pay
for the tyt show yeah they want to get
it all at once i like to get it all at
once and so that's how that's why i
still have but i can't wait to where
it's feasible for me to get rid of it
plus it's for the boxing like i said
yeah i got rid of showtime for a little
while and then i missed the whole thing
i was like goddammit i got to get it
back for that boxing yeah what about
just punching a random person no i don't
want to go i don't like to i like to
watch other people fight
bonobos.com is the official outfitter of
the reuben report enter code trr20 for
20 off your first purchase